we just ran out of time
Kiros they claim to fight for the things
that matter in life truth family law
order and most of all
for life itself
why is it every time I come to visit
there's always a crisis under need to
understand them just tell me what I can
do know if I have universe is a complex
piece of machinery and balance must be
maintained one change requires another
how would you propose I keep the balance
will you help me save bury and car up or
not no but I will give you the means to
save them tell me what you need an
exchange whatever the multiverse
requires to survive the crisis that is
looming
when it is time so if I could have every
what does the multiverse require you
assist me as we seek to prevent the
inevitable that sounds impossible the
multiverse is more complex than you
could fathom what are you not telling me
I've seen your future Oliver an extra
boil an unavoidable I have watched you
die tearing this crisis I'm truly sorry
I cannot pretend his passing but he can
prevent the death of countless morons me
you and your daughter but he needs to
come with me tonight
[Music]
you have great power even though you've
been raised as a human being you're not
one of them
hi everyone happy crisis year so there's
a whole bunch of crisis on Infinite
Earths flash season six arrow season
eight news they announced a whole bunch
of characters that we didn't know about
before Stephen Amell has been talking
about bringing Tom Welling and
canonizing all his small bill stuff so
we'll break it all down we're doing an
IMAX take a giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best crisis on Infinite Earths
theory on the video all this stuff is
information that they revealed publicly
so I don't consider this spoilery so
just doing this top five style at number
five Brandon Routh has totally been
confirmed as the Kingdom Come version of
Superman
during the crossover there was some
confusion on the last trailer video I
did at Comic Con about which version of
Superman he would play during the Comic
Con panel if they said Kingdom Come
Superman but people on the video are
like no they're never gonna let him be
Kingdom Come Superman no it's officially
confirmed that's the version that he's
playing he even came out on stage
wearing a Kingdom Come
outfit but what they're doing is is
they're canonizing the events of
Superman Returns his Superman movie from
back in 2006 to the arrowverse like they
did with small go previously and they're
saying that that version of Superman
became Kingdom comes Superman if you
haven't read the comic book story for it
it's amazing it's one of the best DC
stories of all time
check it out but it's this alternate
dystopian future so it's a much older
version of Superman which is why he has
the white streaks in his hair what
they'll probably do is just put him in a
Kingdom Come outfit but the kingdom
comes Superman suit looks almost exactly
like the Superman Returns suit the
emblem is different but that's about it
he wears the same type of red trunks the
same belt with the loops over it because
they're also bringing Tyler hoechlin
Superman back and they're gonna show us
his version of Lois Lane in the baby
that they just had starting at the
crossover last year remember she was
pregnant they went away to have the baby
and then come back if they wind up
killing a version of Superman because
they have to kill at least a couple big
characters during the crossover they'll
probably kill Brandon Ralph's Kingdom
Come Superman because it's already a
big deal that they let the CW shows do a
version of Superman to begin with
they're not gonna let them do a couple
different versions all at the same time
usually when they get approval to do big
characters like that it's only for a
one-off thing so what's the biggest
thing you can do if you could only use
that character once well he sacrifices
himself in some huge epic display and
you kill the character off it it winds
up being this huge moment for really big
news just this morning they announced
that Black Lightning is gonna be in the
crossover a lot of you have been asking
about Black Lightning for a while the
viewership for that show overall is
actually pretty small but there are a
lot of you that I see commenting on
videos that I know watch it and have
been asking will Black Lightning be part
of the arrow verse well now apparently
the star is confirming that he's gonna
take part in it and once he does show up
during that crossover that will
officially canonize the events of Black
Lightning - the arrow verse because it's
so hard for them to actually do
crossovers with those characters because
they shoot in Atlanta and all the other
arrow bursts shows shoot in Vancouver
he's probably just gonna have a very
brief cameo they'll probably just do a
montage with a bunch of different
versions of earth showing how the
anti-monitor is wrecking the entire
multiverse and in a couple scenes we'll
just see him on his earth witnessing
what's going on they haven't confirmed
how many universes they're gonna wind up
destroying and whether or not they're
gonna fold Supergirl into earth ones
continuity so this easier for her to
cross over with the other characters 3
next big detail Stephen Amell is playing
other characters besides Oliver Queen
during the crossover I'm assuming that
it'll be alternate universes where
Oliver grew up to be somebody else with
a different name but the other people
that he's playing won't just be
alternate Green Arrow's from other
earths the ideas that they're trying to
be as comic-book II as possible so
whoever these other characters he's
playing are they're probably super deep
cuts from the comics they also confirmed
Tommy Merlyn is coming back during arrow
season 8 and he's probably gonna
participate in the crossover but they
said that they're doing a thing that the
fans have been asking for a long time
with his character reading between the
lines that probably means that Tommy
Merlyn will be an alternate dark Archer
during arrow season aid because
everybody kind of wanted to see him
become the next dark Archer but he was
always busy on that other TV show of his
so it's been really hard the last couple
of years for him to come back and cameo
on the show but now because he left that
other
show that he was on he's completely free
to start in a lot of arrow Season eight
episodes to Titan season two is going to
be starting September 6th in just a
couple weeks they will air all their
episodes before the crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover is done but as of right
now it doesn't seem like they are
participating in crisis at all right now
it's kind of like a Netflix Marvel and
MCU situation we have a bunch of
characters that are all from the same
comics but you never really see the
characters interact with each other on
screen so I'm assuming all the Titans
stuff is just happening in a different
universe and they will not crossover
during crisis the Titan season 2 trailer
is gonna be dropping really soon they
were gonna drop it during Comic Con but
one of their stuntmen died during Comic
Con weekend and they wanted to honor him
so this is they would drop it in a more
appropriate date so just expect that in
the next couple of weeks but like I said
before Jorah Mormont's is playing their
Batman he's gonna be in a bunch of
episodes Jason Todd is a series regular
he's gonna be in most of the episodes
the actor has been teasing a lot of Red
Hood stuff so it sounds like they're
gonna be setting up for a Red Hood Ark
they have Conner Kent Superboy with
Krypto they have Deathstroke rose Wilson
ravager in a Ravager costume her brother
Jericho the Garth version of Aqualad and
obviously eventually they're gonna put
their Dick Grayson in a Nightwing
costume but they did confirmed that
they're building up to a Judas contract
in season 3 so I think all the
Deathstroke family stuff during season 2
is just gonna be building towards that
and they'll give all the terrorist stuff
from that story line to the Ravager
character and they'll put her on the
team and she'll be the one that betrays
them all number one though a lot of
people have been asking me about this
Tom Welling Superman cameo from his
Smallville in crisis on Infinite Earths
there have been a lot of rumors flying
around the internet Stephen Amell
recently said that they're trying to get
him to come back actively so it sounds
like people are talking to Tom Welling
and if he doesn't wind up coming back
it's because Tom Welling didn't want to
come back not that they didn't try to
get him to come back but if they're
already doing Burt Ward from the 1966
Batman TV series Kingdom Come Superman
Brandon drought and bringing Tom Welling
back would just be a one-off very
special brief thing it feels very
believable that this could happen
it's still just a rumor but it's so
plausible that you're like oh of course
they would have to do something like
that this is supposed to be the biggest
thing that they've ever done in the
history of TV why wouldn't you bring
back Tom Welling for that my guess is is
that if he is going to be in the
crossover they won't confirm that he's
in it until they drop a big trailer and
it'll be like a big trailer reveal like
spider-man and Captain America Civil War
like surprise we have spider-man or they
won't say anything he'll just show up in
the episode and everybody will just crap
their pants here's my big question for
you guys though would you want them to
put Tom Welling in the trailers if it
meant to say like an extra million
people would tune in to watch the
crossover
[Music]
this is a fine balance that you strike
and how much you reveal in the trailers
and if it's gonna mean almost double the
amount of people watching the episode
live when it airs then it's probably
worth it but there are probably going to
be a bunch of surprises that we won't
see until the actual episodes drop
there's a whole bunch of Marvel phase 4
videos that I'm still working on while
you wait for that click here to learn
all about what's going on with
spider-man 3 and click here for my Thor
for love and thunder teaser video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight